how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder and we
finally got some new marvel content
last night during the image we got the
official trailer for the one division
series coming to disney plus
and it did not disappoint the wanda
vision series is one of the most
anticipated marvel series coming to
disney plus
and we've been waiting for the trailer
for a very long time now but it was not
a disappointment it was a very awesome
trailer but it could be a little bit
confusing to some people but don't worry
we're going to break down everything
that you need to know
about this trailer in this video as well
as go over all of the easter eggs and
nodes to the comics
so we'll just jump right in but if
you're new be sure to subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest mcu
news and
breakdowns so breakdowns are really my
favorite type of content to do so we're
gonna try and dive into as much as we
can here
so to start it off we have the marvel
studios logo of course
on an older television set it's very
staticky and then we cut to a scene of a
car
driving down a road now in the car our
wanda and vision and on the back of the
car as you can see it says
just married we then cut to a scene of
wanda envision
back at their home wanda is in her
wedding dress vision is in a suit they
just got back
from their wedding they are officially
mr and mrs
vision the static on the tv clears up a
little bit and we can hear the music
a lot more clear now the music that is
playing in the background
is twilight by the patterns which is a
very fitting song
now the last two lines of the song are
together at last at twilight time
together at last at twilight time now of
course
wanda and vision have been separated
because vision died in avengers infinity
war but now they're back together
at last but the real question is how how
is vision back and of course we're going
to get into that as the trailer goes on
so we go on and everything is in black
and white and this series is going to
mimic some of the old classic tv shows
for example in this scene where vision
says wanda envision
aren't we a fine pair it looks like a
scene taken straight out of the dick van
dyke show we then hear wanda television
this is our home now i want us to fit in
she then uses her magic to change
vision from an android form to a human
form and this is done in a style that
looks
exactly like the show bewitched we then
see the actress
catherine han who is playing the
character that right now is just listed
as
the wacky next door neighbor and a lot
of these older sitcoms did have a wacky
neighbor that would always show up
but of course we know who she is really
playing she is playing agatha harkness
a witch way back from the salem witch
trial times and more on her in just a
second
we go to the next scene where wanda is
setting the table by using her
powers everything is magically floating
into its space where it's supposed to be
on the table she's not actually
physically touching anything but this is
actually a pretty important easter egg
if we look at the scene
if you take a look at the wine bottle
that is being poured and you take a look
at the name of this wine bottle the name
of it is
meson duma free and if you translate the
title of that bottle it translates to
house of contempt but what this really
could translate into
is house of in house of m is a
major marvel storyline where wanda
basically loses her mind and control of
her powers and she transforms the entire
world
into a reality where her and her family
ruled it and mutants were the dominant
species now we've known for a while that
the wanda vision series was going to
have a lot of elements from the house of
m storyline in its story and this is
just a big confirmation of that and a
cool little easter egg but more
importantly it tells us that the reality
in which wanda and vision are currently
living in may not be all that it seems
to be
we cut to the next scene where they have
guests over and debra joe rupp
is asking some pretty personal questions
she asks where did you two move
from how long have you been married and
why don't you have any children
and this scene is extremely important to
the plot of the one division series
one goes and starts to try to tell them
their story
but as you can see by the expression on
her face she doesn't remember it
she can't recall where they moved from
or how long they've been married for
vision then tries to help and he steps
in and he can't remember
either he says we moved from and then he
stops because he can't remember
either and this is kind of like how
inception was
when they were inside a dream but didn't
realize that they were dreaming they
asked
how did i get here and they couldn't
recall and that was a sign that they
were dreaming and this is sort of the
same thing they can't recall where they
moved from how long they've been married
from because this reality
isn't real and after they can't answer
this question their guest gets
mad and this is where reality kind of
starts to fall apart for them now this
is kind of clever on marvel's behalf
as their eyes are opening and they're
realizing that this reality
isn't exactly real the camera starts to
pan out going from an
older smaller frame which tv shows used
to be like to a
wider frame so as their eyes open and
they realize all this the frame opens as
well
so that reality kind of breaks apart but
then we go to
another one and this time we're kind of
going forward and decades we can see
everything start to change from black
and white to color
now what's really interesting here is
that wanda says
is this really happening now this could
mean one of two major things
one is that wanda is actually creating
this new reality
but she doesn't actually know it
subconsciously she's creating this dream
world
a world where vision is back but another
thing that could be happening here is
that agatha harkness is actually the one
creating this reality as well
this is something that kind of happened
in the comics prior to house of m
wanda lost her two children and agatha
harkness erased them from her memory in
an attempt to keep her from going insane
so it could kind of be the same here in
the mcu
wanda lost vision it was a huge huge
loss for her and she also lost her
brother as well so perhaps her and her
powers were becoming a little bit
unstable so agatha harkness created a
fake reality for her to help her and
we'll dive into this more in just a few
scenes
now the next few quick scenes we go
through more decades but we also go
through time periods of wanda and
visions progression
when it starts they just got married
then they go through the process of
being newlyweds and being very very
happy then they have kids
now these kids of course are wiccan and
speed speed goes on to have abilities
like his uncle
quick silver and wicking goes on to have
abilities like his mother
now another awesome thing that we see
here that we actually saw in the first
teaser trailer that marvel studios gave
us during the super bowl
is a comic accurate version of the
scarlet witch
now in this scene it's actually
halloween and she's wearing a costume
and it's kind of a funny little thing
that marvel's doing here referencing the
scarlet witch's comic accurate outfit as
a halloween costume in the show
and if we skip ahead a few scenes the
same is done with vision this is
actually vision's comic accurate costume
now of course he's in the same reality
so it's halloween for him and his
costume is his actual costume from the
comics but then we cut to another
important scene where vision starts to
fly away and he looks like he's
realizing that something just
isn't right and something to note is
that he still has the mind stone in his
head
and this is most likely due to the fact
that vision was most likely brought back
to life by wanda
by creating this alternate reality she
brought back
in her new reality the version of vision
that she knew
and since the very first time she met
him vision has had the mind stone in his
head
so it looks like she actually brought
him back to life in this new reality it
does look like
she is the one that created this reality
but
subconsciously and if we even look at
vision as he lands down in front of this
car
if you take a look at his cape it has a
hole in it so he was brought back to
life but his cape is still damaged after
the battle that he's been in which is
very interesting and could mean
something during the series at one point
but this next scene is perhaps one of
the most important of the trailers he
lands next to the car and he goes up to
agatha harkness
now in the comics agatha harkness is a
witch and she's dressed up as a witch
and the scene
now in this scene she looks severely
lost in thought
almost like she could be cast in a spell
vision manages to wake her up
out of whatever trance she's in and she
is very startled
she looks at him and then in a lot of
confusement she asks him
am i dead and vision confused as well
says no
why would you think that and she says
again just as confused
because you are so she actually knows
that vision has
died in the real reality she thinks that
she might have died and is now in some
type of afterlife where vision is there
as well because he died
she then laughs like the wicked witch of
the west from the wizard of oz who she
is most likely dressed up as
but this is probably taken out of
context so it's really hard to tell what
she's laughing at this point
but if i had to guess i would say that
she's probably realized that wanda
actually created a different reality
and brought vision back to life in that
reality now what's interesting is that
vision doesn't seem to have any memory
of him dying
it seems like him being dead like agatha
hartness said is
news to him we then go to another very
important scene
it's a scene where wanda starts to shape
the reality around her but in this scene
as she's doing this
it kind of looks like she's in distress
and again like i said in the comics she
kind of has a mental breakdown so that
could be
something that we're seeing right here
in the scene now this scene could be two
different things
this could be her realizing that she's
not in her actual reality it's a new
made up reality
one in which she controls or this could
be in the very beginning of the wanda
vision series perhaps after
infinity war she gets kind of depressed
and she wants to create something
different for herself
so what does she do she starts to do
that she starts to change
reality if this is the case then wanda
consciously has changed the reality
around her and this could actually
explain an upcoming scene but first
notice her hands when she does the magic
to change reality
it looks an awful lot like the way
doctor strange does his magic
now in this series we're going to see a
little bit more of her actual
abilities in the comics she uses
witchcraft and a big power of hers as
the ability to alter reality
and we're finally going to see more of
that or see it for the first time in the
mcu
and of course we know that the one
division series is going to lead up and
tie into
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness so perhaps there's going to be
some connection there but then we go to
the next scene which is a very
interesting scene
of monica rambo being shot out of
whatever reality that wanda and vision
are in
and as you can see the red magic around
her it's wanda who's actually sending
her out of the reality
so this could further prove that wanda
is indeed the one
creating this reality now when wanda
originally sends her through the air
it's daytime but when she leaves the
reality
it's night time and when she lands a
bunch of sword agents go up to her and
if you look
very closely in the back we can see
darcy from
thor she's pretty hard to see but if you
freeze frame and you take a look at the
woman wearing the beanie that's darcy
seemingly working for sword now if
you're wondering whose sword is they are
basically shield they're just a
different department and really their
main priority is to deal with things
from
space other worldly things but what's
interesting is that when monica rambo
gets thrown from the reality it looks
like she's kind of
exiting a tv like she's being thrown
through a screen and if you look at the
scene there seems to be some sort of a
base
established around where she exited so
it looks like everybody is well aware
that wanda has created a different
reality
perhaps in a very real town and now
she's simply altering the town
and making it whatever she wants it to
be her perfect world her perfect reality
now of course we saw monica rambo and
captain marvel she's now all grown up
and she's played by
tayonna paris now in the comics she
actually goes on to become the second
captain marvel and at one point she even
goes by the name spectrum now her powers
are energy energy absorption
manipulation
generation when she's in her energy form
she can travel at the speed of light so
perhaps she's working for shield because
of these powers perhaps her powers
enable her to
enter this reality that wanda has
created because clearly the outside
world has noticed that wanda has created
this reality
they're aware of who she is because she
was an avenger and they need to try and
stop her so they call
in monica rambo or perhaps monica rambo
was
in the town where wanda shaped reality
and perhaps this is where she gets her
powers but it seems like she went into
this reality to do a little bit of spy
work
wanda found out about it and sent her
out so how exactly do you stop
someone as powerful as wanda well it
seems like that's where agatha harkness
could come in because she's shown
many different times in this trailer and
she clearly knows vision is supposed to
be dead
but she's also in this new reality so
perhaps she could be working for shield
and perhaps she's going to try and help
wanda deal with how things are but the
trailer does end on a
light and happy note wanda and vision
back in their living room back in black
and white again
and wanda says we are an unusual couple
you know and vision says oh i don't
think that was ever in question you can
hear
a live audience effect laugh in the
background and we see wanda and vision
smile at the camera but of course we
know that this isn't really
real and that is my wanda vision trailer
breakdown let me know are there any
easter eggs that i may have missed that
you saw
and of course let me know what you
thought about this trailer in the
comments down below and if you have any
theories of your own
don't forget to give this video a like
and subscribe so you can stay up to date
on all of the latest mcu news
for live updates and giveaways you can
follow me on twitter and instagram and
as always thank you all so
much for watching woof
you